Listener, I got to tell you, I'm early for the session today, but it's fortunate because the light in the room that I record this in is just so, it's delicious, and there's a sunbeam just catching my mouth, just perfectly right now. No other part of my face is lit except my mouth, which is perfect because that's all I'm going to be using for the next hour. I'm going to have to chase the sun a bit so if my signal breaks up in the middle of this interview, you're going to know why, but my God, if you could see my mouth right now. If it looks as good as it sounds, you're looking at it correctly.
听众朋友，我必须得说，我今天提前到了录制现场，不过这挺走运的，因为我录音这个房间里的光线太好了，简直绝了，此时此刻正有一道阳光完美地洒在我的嘴上。我脸上的其他地方都没被照亮，只有嘴巴，这太完美了，因为在接下来的一小时里我只需要用到它。我一会儿还得顺着太阳转的方向挪一挪，所以如果我的信号在这场采访的中途断了，你们就知道原因了，但天哪，要是你们现在能看到我的嘴。如果它看起来跟听起来一样好的话，你们现在就看对地方了。
I actually was on a flight once and we started down the runway and like started to speed up, speed up, speed up, and they had that thing, remember these just sometimes put, they had the camera on the front of the plane so you can see the runway. Yes. And it was like a, you know, whatever, big carrier, going down the runway, and then slowed down and then peeled off, like whoa, and the pilot's like, well, we've got a bit of an issue here, we're going to go back to the gate here and take a look. We sat on the plane for like 90 minutes and he's like, we start to pull back from the
其实我以前坐过一次飞机，当时我们上了跑道，然后开始加速、加速、加速，他们有那种——有时会装上这个，它们在飞机前头装了摄像头，所以你能看到跑道。对。那就像是一架，你知道的，不管什么大航司的飞机，在跑道上滑行，然后减速，接着又拐弯离开，就像“哇”，飞行员就说，嗯，我们这儿出了点小状况，我们要回登机口去检查一下。我们在飞机上坐了大概90分钟，然后他说，我们开始从
gate and he's like, okay, we think we've got it taken care of here, so we're just going to give it another shot and I'm like, give it another shot. Isn't that strange how you never meet the pilot? I mean, it is, your life is 1000% in this person's hands. When would you ever put your life and the life of your family in anyone's hands that you haven't met? And you're going to do that for a few hours. Hang on, let me just say, when would I ever put my life and the life of my family in
登机口退出来，他说，好吧，我们觉得这事儿搞定了，所以我们再试一次，而我就想，再试一次。你不觉得从来见不到飞行员这事儿很奇怪吗？我是说，确实很奇怪，你的命1000%掌握在这个人手里。你什么时候会把自个儿和家人的性命交到一个你根本没见过的人手里？而且你要把这事儿交给他们好几个小时。等等，让我说一句，我什么时候才会把我和家人的命交到
the air? That was rhetorical. Oh, that was rhetorical. Yeah, kind of. Okay. Yeah, you know, that's so interesting. I have a little fear, we talked about that last time, about the turbulence and stuff like that, a little bit of that.
空中？那是反问句。哦，原来那是反问句。对，算是吧。好吧。对，你知道，这太有意思了。我有点害怕，我们上次聊过这个，关于颠簸之类的，有点这方面的小恐惧。
Yeah, looks like you have a fear of waking up too. What are you still, I mean, it's not early. And your jail. It is early to me. I just have a fear of hair product. I have no product in my hair. I just had a bagel with flammable up there. Flammable?
对，看样子你也有醒来恐惧症。你现在还在，我是说，这不早。而且你还在禁闭中。对我来说这挺早的。我只是对美发产品有恐惧症。我头发上什么产品都没用。我刚吃了百吉饼，上面有可燃物。可燃物？
Yeah, keep it away from flame. How, what are we at days wise from seeing Scevo? Like from the last one to the next one, where are we at? What's the guy who cuts his hair, Tracy? Yeah, I just saw him last week. Yeah, he's great. You just saw him, okay, you saw him last week on like on a bus bench or you weren't in the salon.
对，离火源远点。话说，距离我们上次见斯塞沃（Scevo），现在过去多少天了？就是从上一次到下一次，我们现在进度到哪了？那个剪头发的叫什么来着，特雷西（Tracy）？对，我上周刚见过他。对，他挺好的。你刚见过他，好吧，你上周见他是在公交站的长椅上，还是你不在沙龙里？
And he had scissors. No, I was not in the salon. No, you weren't. I was on a photo shoot. You were on a bus. Oh, you were on a photo shoot. First of all, let me just say it's 9.30 in the morning. It's 9.30 in the morning.
他手里拿着剪刀。不，我不在沙龙里。不，你不在。我在拍照片。你在公交车上。哦，你在拍照片。首先，让我说一句，现在是早上9点30分。现在是早上9点30分。
This is one of the earlier records we've ever done. I kind of like it. And so far, I got to say we're feeling it. Yeah, I like it. It's kind of low energy. It's like breakfast energy. Now listen, I would say this because we, you know, I want to get to our guests, but Jay, you have a real, everybody's got a real relaxed vibe.
这是我们做过的最早的录制之一。我其实挺喜欢的。而且到目前为止，我得说我们状态不错。对，我喜欢。这有种低能量的感觉。就像早餐时的能量。现在听着，我之所以这么说，因为我们，你知道的，我想聊聊我们的嘉宾，不过杰伊，你真的有一种，每个人都有一种非常放松的氛围。
You got a real relaxed hoodie on today with no tea underneath. Here's a tea. It's a... Is this sleepwear? It's a limpy tea. It's a limpy tea. Oh, and it's also the same color. Look at that.
你今天穿了一件非常放松的连帽衫，里面没有T恤。这儿有件T恤。这是一件……这是睡衣吗？这是一件软塌塌的T恤。这是一件软塌塌的T恤。哦，而且颜色也一样。你瞧。
You have me in my bedwear. Okay. But this is what I was going to say before. I started... I don't know why I thought of this. I... Scotty and I started doing this at night where we open the door. Well, mind me who Scotty is again real quick.
你把我弄得像穿了睡衣一样。好吧。但这是我之前要说的。我开始……我不知道我为什么会想起这个。我……斯科蒂和我开始在夜里这样做，我们把门打开。呃，提醒我一下斯科蒂是谁来着。
Tell me what you do at night. We open the door and even though it's kind of hot, we open the door and we open the door and we put it on the fan. It reminds me of being a kid when we didn't have AC. God, what a great story. And then I make a bowl of ice cream and watch a movie. I had a whole box of sweetest fish. Sometimes we don't eat at night just so I can really relate to all the people who are
告诉我你们晚上干什么。我们把门打开，尽管天气有点热，我们还是把门打开，把门打开，然后把电风扇开着。这让我想起小时候我们没有空调的时候。天哪，多棒的故事啊。然后我做一碗冰淇淋，看一部电影。我吃了一整盒瑞典鱼软糖。有时候我们晚上不吃东西，只是为了让我能真正体会到世界上所有
starving in the world. No, no. And then I have a bowl of ice cream or something cool. But last night I had a whole box of sweetest fish and it didn't stay inside me. It didn't stay inside you. Oh, so weird. I'm through the math. So, but you know, usually those things now, are you sure it wasn't the back end of the
挨饿的人。不，不。然后我吃一碗冰淇淋或者什么凉的东西。但昨晚我吃了一整盒瑞典鱼软糖，它没在我肚子里面待住。它没在你肚子里面待住？哦，太诡异了。我在琢磨这事儿。所以，但是你知道，通常那些东西现在，你确定不是你在好莱坞碗（Hollywood Bowl）买的
box you bought at Hollywood Bowl? No, because no, I bought a second box. Yeah. Buddy, you're not. You barfed. You barfed last night? No, no, no, it came out the other way. Oh, well, then that's just natural.
那盒的后半部分吗？不，因为不，我又买了一盒。老兄，你不是。你吐了。你昨晚吐了？不，不，不，它是从另一头出来的。哦，那这就很自然了。
You don't need to tell me. I assume that all food you eat is going to come out the other. Just for what it's worth. Well, it didn't stay inside me very long. And doesn't it create a plug? Those things? Those gummy bears? I mean, it's.
你不用告诉我。我默认你吃的所有食物都会从另一头出来。权当我没说吧。嗯，它在我肚子里没待多久。而且那不会造成堵塞吗？那些东西？那些小熊软糖？我是说，这。
Come on. Why are we going? I'm surprised you and Scotty did that last night because I know, I know how you are. I know you always. He's always got a fan. You open the doors. You put a fan on. No, he loves a fan.
拜托。我们怎么又说到这儿了？我很惊讶昨晚你和斯科蒂会那样做，因为我知道，我了解你是怎样的人。我知道你总是。他总是开着风扇。你们开着门。你们开着风扇。不，他超爱风扇。
He loves a fan. Yeah. It's so good. Always a fan for a fan. Hey, listen, speaking of fans, I'm a fan of our guest today. Oh, nice. What a great segue. Thank you so much.
他超爱风扇。对。太棒了。风扇的铁杆粉丝。嘿，听着，说到粉丝，我是我们今天嘉宾的粉丝。哦，太棒了。多漂亮的过渡句。非常感谢。
I'm trying to win segue of the year. I think they're going to do it at the webbies next year. I, I've been a fan of this person for a long time and the reason is because this person has done so much in film and television as a director, as a writer, but primarily we know him really for his incredible breadth of work. And this is, and I don't want to embarrass this person, but this is, I, this term you don't throw around very lightly. This is an actor's actor.
我正努力争取年度过渡句奖呢。我想他们明年会在威比奖（Webbies）上颁发这个奖。我，我当这个人的粉丝很久了，原因是因为这个人作为导演、作为编剧，在电影和电视领域做了太多的工作，但主要是我们真正了解他，是因为他那令人难以置信的广阔作品序列。而且，我不想让这个人尴尬，但这，我，这个词你不会轻易随便用。这是一个演员中的演员。
This is somebody who's done it all. This is. Is this a story? This person cannot be. This is a storyteller. This person cannot be defined. He is a movie star and he is a character actor. He is all of these things combined.
这是一个经历过这一切的人。这是一个。这是一个故事吗？这个人无法被。这是一个讲故事的人。这个人无法被定义。他是一个电影明星，也是一个性格演员。他是所有这些身份的结合体。
I swear to God, it is one of the most incredible. This person has had so many different stages to his career and done so many amazing things. And I don't really know him that well. We met a couple of times. And you're not saying like what movie or anything because we'll get it right away. Well, yeah. Well, here, once I start going, and the list is so long that it's got its own page on Wikipedia for his filmography.
我向上帝发誓，这是最不可思议的事情之一。这个人经历过他职业生涯中那么多不同的阶段，做过那么多了不起的事情。而且我其实不是很了解他。我们见过几次面。而你又不说是什么电影之类的，因为我们马上就能猜到。嗯，对。嗯，在这里，一旦我开始说，而且这个名单太长了，以至于他的电影作品在维基百科上都有专门的一页。
No way. His first film was Animal House. Then I'm going to jump a little bit just so to try to throw you off. Jamie Widows. JFK. A few good men, Apollo 13. Sleepers. Is this Mr. Bacon?
真的假的？他的第一部电影是《动物屋》（Animal House）。然后我要跳过一点，试着把你们难倒一下。《维多利亚绝杀令》（Jamie Widows）。《刺杀肯尼迪》（JFK）。《义海雄风》（A few good men）、《阿波罗13号》（Apollo 13）。《沉睡者》（Sleepers）。这是培根先生吗？
Patriot Day. Then I'm going to go back to. Is this Mr. Bacon? A bunch of, but then what, the thing that really shot him to superstardom was a film that we all still love. Footloose, Cutful Loose is Mr. Kevin Bacon. Wow. Incredible Kevin Bacon.
《爱国者日》（Patriot Day）。然后我要回到。这是培根先生吗？一堆，但接着什么，真正让他一炮而红的是一部我们至今仍然喜爱的电影。就是《浑身是劲》（Footloose），剪掉《浑身是劲》的是凯文·培根（Kevin Bacon）先生。哇。不可思议的凯文·培根。
Dun dun dun. I'm trying to unsee Sean's bowl full of Swedish fish. All the fish swimming out of his colon. Oh, so is Scotty. Scotty's in the corner crying somewhere. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. It's so cool to see you.
咚咚咚。我正努力把肖恩那一碗瑞典鱼软糖的画面从脑子里赶出去。所有的鱼都从他的结肠里游出来。哦，斯科蒂也是。斯科蒂在角落里某个地方哭呢。我的天啊。我的天啊。很高兴见到你。
Hey, man. Welcome. I haven't seen you since Will and Grace. I know. I know. Have you been? I know. And I've been good.
嘿，老兄。欢迎。自从《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）之后我就没见过你了。我知道。我知道。你最近怎么样？我知道。我挺好的。
I can't tell you how many times I'll do that walking through the airport thing. Sean and people will come up to me and say, do you know what the best thing you ever did was? And it'll be Will and Grace. And it doesn't necessarily pop into my head as that was one of the options. I mean, I had a great time doing it. Don't get me wrong. But yes, that really made an impression on people.
我无法告诉你我有多少次在走过机场时会经历这种事，肖恩，人们会走过来对我说，你知道你做过最好的事是什么吗？然后就会说是《威尔与格蕾丝》。这并不一定立刻会作为选项之一浮现在我的脑海里。我是说，我拍得很开心。别误会我的意思。但确实，那给人们留下了深刻的印象。
You're going to have to narrow it down because my filmography is like a thousand credits. So let me tell you what I think the best. Hey, you know what? It's so funny. I was just talking about Footloose the other day. And is it true that Tom Cruise was almost up for that part or up for that part? And you got it or something like that? Probably.
你得把范围缩小一点，因为我的电影作品有一千多部。所以让我告诉你我认为最好的。嘿，你知道吗？太搞笑了。我前几天还在谈论《浑身是劲》。汤姆·克鲁斯（Tom Cruise）差点试镜那个角色或者说争取过那个角色，这是真的吗？然后你得到了它或者诸如此类的事？可能吧。
Yeah, probably. I mean, I think all the young dudes were up for it. Going at it. It was just one of those things, you know? Yeah. So here I am on Smart List, Bucket List. So cool. All I could think, my wife said, clearly they have run out of important celebrities.
对，可能吧。我是说，我想所有年轻小伙子都去争取过。都在竞争。这就是那种事儿，你知道的？所以现在我来到了“智能清单”（Smart List）、“遗愿清单”（Bucket List）。太酷了。我能想到的，我妻子说，很明显他们已经找不到重要的名人了。
They've made their way down to you after, how was it a thousand and thirty-five episodes or something like that? Which, by the way, I've listened to every single one of them. I listened to every single fucking episode of my life. Oh, my God. Yes. Absolutely true. Kevin, that speaks less to how the quality of our show and more to your profound boredom,
在经历了，是多少，一千零三十五集还是差不多这样的集数之后，他们终于沦落到找你了？顺便说一句，我每一集都听了。我听了我人生中每一期他妈的节目。哦，天哪。是的。绝对千真万确。凯文，这说明不了我们节目的质量有多高，只能说明你有多么深刻的无聊，
I think. So, Kevin, you know, I've had the good fortune of bumping into you just a couple of times, and I'm always just kind of buzzing after I finish saying hi to you and your wife. And you guys are just always so kind and nice to me and pleasant to even the person you were talking to before you talked to me and the person afterwards. Where do you think that, like, were you always like that or does this come as a result of you both being in this business for so long and have such a well-earned appreciation for your longevity and, you know, is that why you're so kind to everybody?
我觉得。所以，凯文，你知道的，我有幸跟你偶遇过几次，每次跟我和你妻子打完招呼后，我总是觉得整个人兴奋得嗡嗡作响。你们俩总是对我都那么善良、友好和蔼，甚至对你在跟我说话之前交谈过的人以及之后的人也是如此。你觉得，这种特质，你是本来就一直这样，还是因为你们俩在这个行业待了太久，对自己的长青有着来之不易的感激之情，所以才变成这样的？你知道，这就是你对所有人都那么友善的原因吗？
I love being an actor and I feel just a tremendous amount of gratitude to be able to do what I do. And when it comes to being kind to people, I know, I kind of feel like that really is like, I think my mother was very much, you know, like influential in terms of that kind of stuff. I think my dad was somebody who was very driven and I kind of got the success thing from him, you know, the drive. Sean said was driven.
我热爱当演员，对于能够做自己想做的事，我内心充满极大的感激。而说到对人友善，我知道，我总觉得这真的就像，我觉得我母亲在这类事情上对我影响非常大。我觉得我父亲是一个非常有进取心的人，我大概是从他那里继承了对成功的渴望，那种拼劲。肖恩说很有进取心。
Yeah, I know. Sorry, that was such a softball. Thanks, pal. I don't let those go by. I was not planning on tossing that one to him. My dad was the driver who wasn't driven. Yeah, that's right. We do have to get a screeching tire sound effect on this podcast.
对，我知道。抱歉，那球抛得太好接了。谢谢你，老兄。我可不会放过这种机会。我可没打算把那个球抛给他。我爸是个开车的人，但不是个有进取心的人。对，没错。我们必须在这个播客里加上一个刺耳的轮胎摩擦音效。
He was driven away in a Mazda. Now you know that I've listened to the show when I didn't even question what you were talking about. I know. That's true. Clearly I knew exactly. Good test. Yeah, all you had to say was Sean's dad was and I knew where it was going.
他被一辆马自达（Mazda）拉走了。现在你知道我是听过节目的了吧，因为我甚至都没去质疑你在说什么。我知道。确实如此。很显然我完全懂。好测试。对，你只要说肖恩的爸爸是……我就知道话题要往哪走了。
But you know what? We should have known something was up when he bought an MG. Remember those cars, the MGs? Yeah. He did. He really did. Oh yeah. Oh boy.
但你知道吗？当他买了一辆MG跑车时，我们就该知道他不对劲了。还记得那些车吗，MG？对。他确实买过。真的买过。哦，对。哦，天哪。
Yeah, what is that? We're all like, can't eat. And he's like, I bought an MG. Nice car. That's cool. You should have known when he bought new luggage. So your mom said a good example. Dad was a little bit more driven.
对，那是啥？我们都在想，饭都吃不起了。而他却说，我买了一辆MG。好车。挺酷的。他买新行李箱的时候你就该知道了。所以你妈妈树立了一个好榜样。爸爸更有进取心一点。
Yeah. My mom said a good example for compassion and being kind to people and stuff like that. And listen, I love to meet people that do what we do and to say hi and connect. And I have a certain kind of separation and a funny kind of way from our industry. It's weird kind of like I've never felt 100% sort of in it in the community in a weird kind of way. And I, you know, when I listen to you guys, I'm like, geez, I want to be, you know, baking cookies with Jennifer Aniston or, you know, playing pickleball with Brian Reynolds or
对。我妈妈为同理心、对人友善之类的事情树立了一个好榜样。听着，我喜欢结识和我们做同行的人，打个招呼，建立联系。我对我们的行业有一种奇特的疏离感，还有一种搞笑的距离感。这种感觉挺奇怪的，从某种奇怪的角度来说，我从来没有百分之百觉得自己融入了这个圈子。而且，你知道，当我听你们几个聊天时，我就想，天哪，我也想跟詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）一起烤饼干，或者，你知道的，跟布莱恩·雷诺兹（Brian Reynolds）一起打匹克球，
whatever it is. You know, it's like I listen, I go, shit, that sounds like fun. But you know, being like in staying in New York and stuff like that. So when I do run into someone like any one of you guys, you know, I'm genuinely excited. It's like, it's not something that I do in a normal course. Jason's very interested. Jason's interested. He asked you that because he's like, how, that's so interesting to be nice to people
或者诸如此类的事。你知道，就像我听着节目，心想，操，听起来真好玩。但你知道的，呆在纽约之类的。所以每当真碰上你们当中的某个人时，你知道的，我是发自内心地兴奋。这可不是我日常会做的事。杰伊很感兴趣。杰伊很感兴趣。他那样问你是因为他在想，哇，对人友善这事儿太有意思了，就像，你是怎么做到的，我怎么才能做到呢？就像他也想变得那样。所以他是对的。杰伊视你为榜样。对。我就是参不透。你知道的。
like, how do you, how would I get there? Like he wants to be as well. So he's right. Jay is aspirational for you. Yes. I just can't crack it. You know. Do you, is it, is it, is it hard for you to keep that, that pleasantness up?
你，这种和善，你觉得，你觉得保持这种和善很难吗？
I just walk in the streets there in New York because I would imagine, because I know what Jason's saying. Let me, let me finish the sentence because he's so recognizable. He's been, as you said, in everything and that is an incredible accomplishment. His longevity is stunning. So I'd imagine you can't walk into a room, a restaurant, a subway car, anything without someone wanting to talk to you, especially if you're, if you have this big flashing green light up of like a smile and like, Hey, I'm approachable.
我只是走在纽约的街头，因为我能想象，因为我懂杰伊的意思。让我，让我把话说完，因为他太有辨识度了。正如你所说，他演过所有作品，这是一个了不起的成就。他的艺术生命长青得令人惊叹。所以我猜你走进任何一个房间、一家餐馆、一节地铁车厢，不管去哪，都会有人想跟你说话，特别是如果你，如果你脸上挂着一个巨大的闪烁绿灯般的微笑，就像是在说，“嘿，我很平易近人。
Come on up and take a picture. Like, does that get tough for you because you're so known? I don't walk around honestly with the approachable smile on my face. I have the opposite. I walk around with the opposite smile. It's the opposite. Consciously. It's, yeah.
快来找我合影吧。”你会不会觉得这很难对付，因为你太出名了？说实话，我走在路上脸上可不会挂着那种平易近人的微笑。我有相反的表情。我走在路上时脸上是相反的微笑。正好相反。有意识地。是的。
I mean, well, just over years of doing it. And this is what I think, you know, well, first of all, you've been famous for 40 years. I mean, you know what I mean? Yeah. Right. So you got to get used to it as eventually. And I have no one to blame but myself and 99% of being famous is good. Fuck.
我是说，好吧，只是多年来一直如此。这就是我的想法，你知道，首先，你已经红了40年了。我是说，你知道我的意思吧？对。没错。所以你最终总得习惯它。而且我怨不得别人，只能怪我自己，出名带来的好处占了99%。操。
People give you shit. They, they say, they tell you, people stop you and say, I love you. It's like to be told that you're, somebody loves you. Yeah. Yeah. That's like gold. You know. Yeah.
人们会给你捧场。他们，他们会说，他们会告诉你，人们会拦住你说，我爱你。这种感觉就像是有人对你说他们爱你。对。对。这简直就像金子一样。你知道。对。
I would imagine you get that a lot. You're a very, very, very well-known actor, very famous actor, but you're not a celebrity. You know, like, I feel like the celebrities are the ones that when they're walking down the street, people take a picture because it's like an animal escaped the zoo. Like, I got to get a shot of this walking down the street. I imagine people that come up and talk to you are like, hey, Kevin, I loved you on Will and Grace. Hey, keep it going.
我猜你经常听到这样的话。你是一个非常、非常、非常知名的演员，一个非常著名的演员，但你不是那种大红大紫的流量明星。你知道，就像，我觉得那些流量明星是那种走在街上时，人们会拍照，因为那感觉就像一只动物从动物园里逃出来了一样。就像，我得拍下这个走在街上的人。我猜那些走过来跟你说话的人会说，“嘿，凯文，我很喜欢你在《威尔与格蕾丝》里的表演。嘿，继续加油。”
You know. Exactly. And then, and then off you go. And you don't really get hassled that much. And yeah. So it does get a little bit much, but like I say, it's all my fault. And I just have to know that when I leave the house, it's, you know, that's going to be a thing.
你知道的。完全正确。然后，然后你就可以走了。你其实不会受到太多的骚扰。所以，虽然这确实有点过头了，但就像我说的，这全怪我自己。我只需要知道，当我离开家的时候，你知道的，这肯定会发生。
I'll tell you, the one thing that has definitely has changed, though, is that when I became famous out of a thousand people, one person had a camera, and now out of a thousand people, a thousand people have a camera, only one person actually knows how to use it. So it slows things down, you know, just in life. No more autographs. Yeah, nobody gives a shit about autographs anymore, except for those guys that I call the blue men, you know, who are the guys that they always, they always have you signed with a blue Sharpie and they have just stacks of, right.
我告诉你，唯一真正改变的事情是，以前当我变得出名时，一千个人里只有一个人有相机，而现在一千个人里每个人都有相机，但只有一个人真正知道怎么用。所以这把生活节奏变慢了，你知道的，就在生活中。不再有签名了。对，再也没人在乎签名了，除了那些我称之为“蓝衣人”的家伙，你知道的，就是那些总是，他们总是让你用一支蓝色记号笔签名，而且他们手里有一叠一叠的，对吧。
Don't personalize it so they can sell it at the airports and stuff like that. Sean knows a bunch of blue men, but it's a different David Cross knows a bunch of blue men too. But you know what? I feel bad, Kevin, because now we've blown up your spot. Like, like you're walking around with a scowl, but people now know that underneath you're such a nice guy. So they're like, Oh, that's just his walk around face.
不要写上定制的名字，这样他们就可以把它拿到机场之类的地方去卖。肖恩认识一帮蓝衣人，不过大卫·克罗斯（David Cross）也认识一帮蓝衣人。但你知道吗，凯文，我觉得挺不好意思的，因为现在我们把你的底牌给揭穿了。就像，你平时虽然板着脸走路，但现在大家知道了，其实你骨子里是个这么好的人。所以他们会想，“哦，那只是他平时的路人脸。
I'll go up. Yeah. Yeah. But, you know, the thing is that I don't want to stop being able to move. Yeah. That's why I love New York partly is because I really, it's a city where if I stay out of the neighborhoods that are super touristy, people just don't fuck with you because they're too busy.
我得走过去。”对。对。但是，问题是，我不想失去自由活动的能力。对。这也是我部分喜爱纽约的原因，因为它是一个这样的城市，如果我避开那些超级游客聚集的街区，人们根本不会烦你，因为他们太忙了。
They're just kind of like, they'll say, you know, how you doing? But that, but like that's it. I've always got to say over the years, I've seen so many, I've seen, you know, you're again, you've been just part of our sort of cultural fabric for a long time and any photo I have to admit this to you is, I think you've got, this is crazy. I think you've got great style and I've always thought nobody rocks a fucking jean jacket like Kevin Bacon. That's right.
他们差不多只会说，你知道的，“最近怎么样？”但也就这样了。我一直得说，这些年来，我见过太多，我见过，你知道的，你再次成为了我们某种文化面孔的一部分已经很久了，而且任何照片我都必须向你承认这一点，我觉得你有，这太疯狂了。我觉得你有着极佳的穿搭风格，我一直认为没有人能把一件该死的牛仔夹克穿得像凯文·培根那么有范儿。没错。
I've thought this for years, man. That's right. It's my jean jacket. I was going to wear my jean jacket and I forgot. I love the jean jacket and nobody does it better than you, dude, ever. And you still look 17 too. I know. It's amazing.
我多年来一直这么想，老兄。没错。这就是我的牛仔夹克。我本打算穿我的牛仔夹克来着，结果给忘。我太喜欢那件牛仔夹克了，没有人能比你穿得更好，老兄，从来没有。而且你看起来依然只有17岁。我知道。太神奇了。
It's just wonderful. Yeah. What's your deal? Why do you look so fucking young? Sean? We were at Scotty's. Swedish fish. Yeah.
简直不可思议。对。你到底有什么秘诀？为什么你看起来这么年轻？肖恩？我们在斯科蒂家。瑞典鱼软糖。对。
He's not bleeding Swedish fish out of his ass. Fuck. Jesus Christ. And they were red. They were red. Get yourself a break. Let's get a message from our sponsor, Swedishfish, real quick. I still eat them knowing.
他的屁股里可没流出瑞典鱼软糖。操。耶稣基督。而且它们是红色的。饶了我吧。让我们听听赞助商瑞典鱼软糖的广告，快。我明知故犯地依然在吃它们。
That's what I'm saying. I still eat them knowing. That's what they do to me. And now a word from our sponsor. And now back to the show. Hey, Kev, can I ask you something? Yes. No, no.
我就是这个意思。我明知故犯地还在吃。这就是它们对我的影响。现在有请我们的赞助商。现在回到节目中。嘿，凯文，我能问你个问题吗？可以。不，不。
Hey, whoa, whoa. I don't think it's Kev. I'm sorry. I'm not sure it's Kev. No, you can Kev me. You can Kev me. My brother's name is Kev. I don't actually like Kev.
嘿，哇，哇。我觉得可能不能叫你凯文。抱歉。我不太确定是不是叫凯文。不，你可以叫我凯文。你可以叫我凯文。我兄弟的名字就叫凯文。我其实并不喜欢凯文这个名字。
This is the truth. I can't stand the name Kev. Really? I didn't like it when I was young. I don't like it now. Kevin, if you read, look at movies and scripts, and even in the UK, they use it as an insult. He's like Kevin.
真的吗？我年轻时就不喜欢。现在也不喜欢。凯文，如果你去看，看看电影和剧本，甚至在英国，他们把这个名字当成一种侮辱。他们会说，他就像个凯文。
You know, it's like a... It's like a Karen. Is that the male Karen? Yeah. It's like a Karen. It's like a Karen. Exactly. It's like a Karen, but it's also like,
你知道，这就像是一个……这就像是个凯伦（Karen）。这是男版凯伦吗？对。这就像是个凯伦。这就像是个凯伦。一点没错。这就像是个凯伦，但它也像是，
you're like, my name's Keith and his name's Kevin and I'm a plaster and he's a plumber. You know, it's like that kind of thing. What? Yeah. It's a real sort of tongue. I'm Kevin. My brother's name is Kevin.
你就像是，我叫基思（Keith），他叫凯文，我是个泥水匠，而他是个水管工。你知道，就是那种感觉。什么？对。这真的是一种讽刺。我是凯文。我兄弟的名字叫凯文。
That's why I default of Kev. My point is that I do like the name Kev. You do like Kev? Yeah. So you're allowed to Kev. You can Kev me all you want. All right. What about K?
这就是为什么我默认自己叫凯文。我的意思是，我其实挺喜欢凯文这个简称的。你喜欢凯文这个简称？对。所以你可以叫我凯文。你想怎么叫我凯文都行。好吧。K怎么样？
Like KB? No? KB. KB is great. Sure. All right. So my question is, and Kevin, we can totally cut this, but I'm only asking because...
比如KB？不行吗？KB。KB挺好的。当然。好吧。所以我的问题是，凯文，我们完全可以把这段剪掉，但我问这个纯粹是因为……
Hard hitting. No, because when I saw it in the news, I was like, oh, my heart went out to you. So we can cut this if you want. But the Bernie Madoff thing, when that happened to you, and I know it was years ago, but I can't imagine what that was like going through that. Like, because I saw, I was like, wait, Kevin Bacon's affected.
犀利提问。不，因为当我在新闻里看到这事时，我想，哦，我的心都为你揪起来了。所以如果你想的话我们可以把这段剪掉。但是伯纳德·麦道夫（Bernie Madoff）那件事，当它发生在你身上时，我知道那是多年前的事了，但我无法想象经历那种事是什么感觉。因为我看到时，我想，等等，凯文·培根也受影响了。
I really did feel so badly. I'm the dummy who doesn't know that story. Yeah, me neither. Oh, that is the story. Just lost some money and made off. Yeah. That's the story. Yeah.
我当时真的觉得太遗憾了。我是那个不知道这个故事的笨蛋。对，我也是。哦，这就是那个故事。就是因麦道夫事件损失了一些钱。对。就是那个故事。对。
And we had most of our money in Madoff. Oh, yay. Yeah, there's obvious life lessons there. If something is too good to be true, it's too good to be true. Right. And when something like that happens, you look at each other,
我们大部分的钱都投在麦道夫那儿了。哦，耶。是的，这里面有显而易见的人生教训。如果一件事好得让人难以置信，那它就是好得难以置信。没错。当那种事发生时，你们互相对视一眼，
and you go, well, that sucks. And let's roll up our sleeves and get to work. We've made it this far. Our kids are healthy. Yeah. We're healthy. Yeah. Let's look at what we have that's good.
然后说，好吧，这真够烂的。让我们卷起袖子开始干活吧。我们已经走到这一步了。我们的孩子们很健康。对。我们很健康。对。让我们看看我们拥有的好东西。
We can still both work. And yeah, I mean, certainly, you get angry and stuff. But I have to say that that dude, there were a lot of people who were much worse off than we were, you know, old people, people whose retirement funds were completely, you know, decimated. Yeah.
我们俩都还能工作。而且，是的，当然，你会生气之类的。但我必须说，那个家伙，有很多人比我们的处境惨得多，你知道的，老年人，他们的退休金被彻底，你知道的，摧残殆尽。对。
So there's always going to be somebody that's going to have it a lot worse than you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And, you know, whatever, the cliché is all, you know, work, whatever it doesn't kill you makes you stronger. And, you know, we just rolled up our sleeves. Right. And also a story.
所以总会有人比你的处境惨得多。对，对，对。而且，不管怎样，老生常谈就是，你知道，工作，不管什么杀不死你的会让你更强大。而且，你知道，我们只是卷起袖子。没错。还有一个故事。
I remember reading this thing that a lot of people were made whole by that in the end. Did you guys recoup any of that? Again, we can cut it. But were you guys get anything back? Or was it? Yeah. Yeah, it's very, it's a complicated thing to explain,
我记得读过这样一件事：最终很多人通过那件事拿回了全部资金。你们收回了一部分钱吗？再说一次，我们可以把它剪掉。但你们拿回什么了吗？还是说？对。对，这是一个很复杂的事情，
which would just be too, I'll be happy to tell you about it someday, but just be too deep in the weeds. But basically, yes, we got sort of like a, you know, a portion of some money back. And there was also, you know, a lawsuit and stuff like that. But, you know, the thing about it is, is that it looks like a certain amount of money, right? There's the money that you put in to something,
解释起来会太麻烦了，我改天很乐意跟你细说，但现在说得太深入了。基本上，是的，我们拿回了一部分钱，诸如此类的。而且，你知道，还有诉讼之类的。但是，你知道，关于这件事的关键在于，它看起来是一笔特定的钱，对吧？有你投入某样东西的钱，
and then there's the money that you've, in theory, gotten accrued with interest over the years. But that's just, that's not real. That's just the number that was on a piece of paper. On a piece of paper, right? Yeah, it was not, it was not a real thing. So you have to really just kind of switch your whole idea about Matrix and stuff like this.
然后还有你在理论上通过这些年的利息累积下来的钱。但那只是，那不是真的。那只是纸上的一串数字。纸上的一串数字，对吧？对，那不是，那不是真的东西。所以你真的必须改变你对《黑客帝国》（Matrix）以及诸如此类事情的整个看法。
I think people will be not happy to hear me whining about money. No, but you know what, I will say this, you know, just listening to the way you talk about it, and it makes no, I read a great article, you know, in anticipation of us talking today from talking about you and having, reaching like a different, having a second wind and stuff, and the article was from 1994, which was almost 30 years ago.
我觉得大家听到我抱怨钱的事不会高兴的。不，但你知道吗，我会这么说，你知道的，只是听你谈论这件事的方式，我觉得，我读过一篇很棒的文章，为了迎接我们今天的谈话，文章谈到了你，谈到了你迎来了第二春之类的，那篇文章是1994年的，距今将近30年了。
And I thought to me, it sort of reinforces this idea that I have that you're a guy who's able to kind of move on and adapt and change. Again, you came out, you were in the biggest movie, you were in Footloose, you were in the cover of People Magazine, you did all that, and you did a bunch of big studio movies, and then all of a sudden you're like, I'm gonna start doing interesting roles
我当时想，这某种程度上印证了我的一个想法：你是一个能够继续前进、适应并改变自我的人。再说一次，你一出道就演了最大的电影，你演了《浑身是劲》，你上了《人物》（People）杂志的封面，你做到了这一切，你拍了一堆好莱坞大制片厂的电影，然后突然之间你说，我要开始拍一些有趣的电影了，
and I wanna work with directors who matter to me. And reading that from 30 years ago, and you've continued to do it, and you've gone like, you know what, I'm gonna do a TV series, I'm gonna do a broadcast series, and now you're doing this cable series sitting on the hill, you've like consistently done stuff, I guess challenge yourself,
我想和那些对我很重要的导演合作。读到30年前的那篇报道，而你一直都在这样做，你还去接了，你知道的，我要拍一部电视剧，我要拍一部广播剧，现在你又在拍这部坐在山上的有线电视剧，你一直都在坚持做各种事情，我想是在挑战自我，
and people say also reinvent yourself, but I don't know, that term is misleading, it's like reinvent to them, to you you're just growing, I would imagine. What is that thing inside you that makes you just kind of wake up every day and go, now I'm gonna go this way, now I'm gonna go that way? I guess it's, I don't know, you know,
人们也说这是在重塑自我，但我不知道，这个词具有误导性，对他们来说是重塑，而对你来说你只是在成长，我猜是这样。你内心深处究竟是什么东西，让你每天醒来都会想，现在我要走这条路，现在我要走那条路？我想这是，我不知道，你知道的，
I'd love to tell you that it was a grand scheme, but it really is just a question of throwing shit against the wall to see what sticks. And also just kind of, you know, when I started out, there was no plan B, so I was just like, okay, this is what I'm gonna do, you know, I moved to New York. And it's what you love to do, so.
我很想告诉你这是一个宏大的计划，但这其实只是把狗屎扔在墙上看看哪坨能粘住的问题。而且也只是，你知道的，自我出道以来，就没有B计划，所以我当时就想，好吧，这就是我要做的，你知道的，我搬到了纽约。而且这也是你热爱的事业，所以。
It's what I love to do, I love it, I love acting, I don't tire of it at all. The time between action and cut to me is still just the best. I love that. The rest of it, I've lost patience for, you know, the things that sort of have to go along with it. But the actual time where I'm on that set, the cameras are rolling with other actors,
这是我热爱的事业，我爱它，我热爱表演，我一点也不觉得厌倦。对我来说，“开拍”和“停机”之间的那段时间依然是最棒的。我爱极了。至于剩下的部分，我已经失去耐心了，你知道的，那些必须随之而来的繁文缛节。但真正身处片场、摄像机在转动、和其他演员一起，
tossing the ball back, I still love it. And I think that, you know, you like to say that, you know, there's no secret to longevity, longevity is a secret. If you just, you know, just fucking hang in there, you know, and if you suck when you begin, you're gonna get better eventually, you know. Right, right.
把球来回抛接的那个时间段，我依然深爱着它。而且我认为，正如你喜欢说的那样，艺术生命没有秘诀，长青本身就是秘诀。如果你只是，你知道的，他妈的坚持下去，而且如果你刚开始时演得很烂，你最终总会变好的，你知道的。对，对。
What was the first paycheck you got for an acting gig? Yeah, I'll tell you, I was about 15 or 16. I was still in Philly. I moved to New York when I was 17, when I got out of high school. But I was still in high school. And so I heard about from a friend of a friend or something that there was this job to be a kid
你接演第一个表演工作的片酬是多少？对，我告诉你，我当时大概15、16岁。我当时还在费城。我17岁高中毕业后搬到了纽约。但我当时还在上高中。然后我从朋友的朋友那里听说，有个工作是去当一个小孩，
in a, it was like a ROTC recruitment video. And it was going to pay, I think, $450 or something like that. I was like freaking out. I was like, this is the greatest thing. Now, my mother was a serious anti-war activist and civil rights activist. Took me down to D.C. when I was a kid, you know, marching on Washington and clearly,
那是一个类似ROTC（预备役军官训练营）的招兵宣传视频。报酬是，我想大概450美元左右。我当时简直快疯了。我心想，这太棒了。现在，我母亲是一个坚定的反战活动家和民权活动家。我小时候她带我去华盛顿，你知道的，在华盛顿游行，很显然，
this was after the Vietnam War had ended, but it wasn't so far on the heels of Vietnam. And she was super anti-military. So I got this gig and I said, I'm taking it and she didn't speak to me for like a week. Oh, wow. Yeah, she was furious. She was furious.
那是越南战争结束之后，但离越战结束没过去多久。她超级反战。所以我接了这份工作，我说我要接下它，结果她大概有一个星期没跟我说话。哦，真的吗？对，她气疯了。她气疯了。
Yeah, but at that moment, you know, at that moment I did that thing that, I think it's Robert Bly talks about, you know, an Iron John where you steal the key underneath the queen's bed. Yeah. It's a, you know, a rite of passage of a young man to walk away from his mother. And which, you know, we all hopefully do eventually.
对，但在那个时刻，你知道的，在那个时刻我做了一件罗伯特·布莱（Robert Bly）谈论过的事，你知道的，就像《铁约翰》（Iron John）里那样，你偷走了女王床底下的钥匙。对。这是一个年轻男子离开母亲的成人礼。而我们所有人，希望最终都能做到这一点。
I was around the same age. I got my ear pierced and my mom didn't talk to me for like a week. And then. And that's your moment, right? And you go, no, I want this. That was his moment. Yeah. I really was a nipple piercing.
我差不多也是那个年纪。我打了耳洞，我妈大概一个星期没跟我说话。然后。那就是你的高光时刻，对吧？然后你说，不，我要这个。那是他的高光时刻。对。其实是乳环。
I think a nipple piercing really sealed it. And your dad put it in drive and that was that. That's right. I'm surprised she could hear you over the erasure music that was playing. Wait, Kev, go ahead, Kevin. Yeah. So that was it. That was the first gig and I went and I did it.
我觉得乳环才是真正敲定这件事的关键。然后你爸踩下了油门，事情就这么定了。没错。我很惊讶你在播放伊拉斯逊（Erasure）乐队音乐的时候还能听到我说话。等等，凯文，你接着说，凯文。对，就是这样。那就是第一份工作，我去了，我完成了。
And, uh, and, and it was awesome. How do you, how do you and Kira have, you, you maintain such an incredible, uh, success story as far as marriage goes. You guys been together so long with, with two very vibrant careers, never working in the same city. I'm sure there's tons of overlap with your schedules. Uh, it's got to be an effort. I mean, to the extent you're comfortable talking, you know, details and strategies.
而且，而且，棒极了。你和基拉（Kyra）是怎么做到的？你们在婚姻方面保持着如此不可思议的成功神话。你们在一起这么长时间了，各自都有着非常红火的职业生涯，而且从来不在同一个城市工作。我确信你们的日程安排有很多重叠的地方。这肯定需要付出努力。我是说，在你觉得舒服的范围内，聊聊细节和策略。
What, what is, what's this, what's the secret there? Um, it's, it's a difficult thing to do, I'm sure. Well, you know, as well as I do that over the years, you learn the power of known and that's the question that I am trying not to answer. Uh, so I will respectfully decline to answer that, but I'm also going to tell you, I'm going to tell you why, I'm going to tell you why I won't answer. And the reason is, is that what happens is you say something like,
那么，那么，秘诀是什么？呃，这肯定是一件很难做到的事，我确信。嗯，正如你和我一样清楚，多年来，你懂得了“不”的力量，这就是我正试图不去回答的问题。呃，所以我将恭敬地拒绝回答，但我也会告诉你们，我会告诉你们原因，我会告诉你们我为什么不回答。原因在于，会发生这样的事：你说了类似的话，
she's my best friend or, you know, um, you know, uh, uh, we just, whatever the fuck it is, you know, just don't fucking quote. And then people use that quote and you take whatever 34 years of marriage and it gets reduced to something that either comes out of my, whether it comes out of my mouth or not. I love that. It's a great answer though, man. I totally, totally, totally agree, especially now more than ever.
“她是我的最好朋友”或者，你知道的，呃，“我们只是……不管他妈的是什么鬼话。”你知道的，就是别他妈的引述。然后人们就会用这句话，把你34年的婚姻给简化成某个东西，不管它是不是从我嘴里说出来的。我喜欢这个回答。不过这是一个很棒的回答，老兄。我完全、完全、完全赞同，尤其是现在，比以往任何时候都更赞同。
I've had instances where like stuff's happened in my life. It was like, it just becomes like a click link. You're like, my life is now a fucking click link. Like what the hell? Yeah, yeah. I'm just curious about that, that whole sort of, um, distance makes relationships difficult, you know, military families, uh, uh, professional athletes, um, uh, anybody that's got an astronaut's great point.
我曾经历过这样的情况：我的生活中发生了一些事。结果就像是变成了一个点击链接。你会想：“我的生活现在居然成了一个他妈的点击链接。”这算什么鬼？对，对。我只是对那个，那种，呃，距离让感情变得艰难的现象感到好奇，你知道的，军人家庭，呃，职业运动员，呃，任何有宇航员的人，真是个绝妙的观点。
Well, their distance couldn't be great. Yeah, exactly. Really far away, but, uh, but because you guys don't, do you guys don't work together a ton, right? You have worked together for sure. No? We have. We have.
好吧，他们的距离可不能算近。对，真的。离得超级远，但是，呃，因为你们不，你们不怎么一起工作，对吧？你们确实一起工作过。没有吗？我们合作过。我们合作过。
Yeah, I've directed her. She's directed me. We've, we've, and we've done a little bit of acting together, but you know, I think that you're making the point. It's true. People think that, um, because of the distance and distance is hard and because you have two actors, I think on a lot of people's minds, they think, well, they're two actors.
对，我导演过她。她导演过我。我们，我们一起演过一点戏，但你知道，我觉得你刚刚说得对。这是真的。人们以为，呃，因为有距离，而且距离很难熬，再加上你们俩都是演员，我想在许多人的脑海里，他们会想，好吧，他们两个都是演员。
So the first thing their mind goes to is like sex scenes or love scenes or kissing other people or all those kinds of things. Yeah. And then, and, and so, so that's what goes into people's minds. And then they think, well, most Hollywood relations break up. And here's the thing. Most marriages break up. Marriage sucks.
所以他们脑子里首先想到的就是亲密戏、爱情戏、或者跟别人接吻之类的所有这些事情。对。而且，而且，所以，这就是人们脑子里想的。然后他们会想，好吧，大多数好莱坞恋情最后都分了。事情是这样的。大多数婚姻都以分手告终。婚姻太烂了。
Marriage doesn't work. Let's face it. The statistics are absolutely terrible. That's our clickbait. No, I don't care. We got it. Thanks, Kevin. You can't, right, exactly.
婚姻根本行不通。面对现实吧。统计数据绝对糟糕透顶。这就是我们的点击诱饵。不，我不在乎。我们录到了。谢谢你，凯文。你不能，对，没错。
There you go. I'm fine. I'm fine going on to record with that because these are just numbers. You know, you can't, but you can't, you can't prove to me that, you know, two dentists have more successful marriages than two actors. I don't know that that statistic really, you know. Right. That being said, I will say that we do plane strains and automobiles
就是这样。我没意见。我很高兴把这些话录进音频里，因为这只是一些数字。你知道的，你不能，但你不能向我证明，你知道的，两个牙医的婚姻就一定比两个演员的婚姻更成功。我不知道那个统计数据是不是真的，你知道的。话虽如此，我要说的是，我们确实会坐飞机、火车和汽车，
to try to get to each other as often as is physically possible. Yeah. Yeah. With the emphasis on physical. Yeah. And with the kids growing up, I'm sure the kids put in another element of complication and challenge. And that's tough to do as well.
尽可能频繁地去看对方，只要物理条件允许。对。对。重点在于“物理上”。对。随着孩子们长大，我确信孩子们又加入了一层复杂性和挑战。这也是很难处理的事。
Right. I mean, all this is just projection. But it's a, again, for the military families and the professional athletes and all that distance that vagabond. Astrodust. Yeah. Astrodust. You guys know, you guys know you've been married a long time.
好吧。所有这些都只是投射。但这，再次说明，对于军人家庭、职业运动员以及所有那些聚少离多的吉普赛生活。太空尘埃。对。太空尘埃。你们知道，你们知道你们结婚很久了。
Yeah. The kids, this is what I think. I am not. Yeah. I know. My kids, well, they were raised in New York. And they, I think that there's challenges to having two famous people as parents that are just inherent.
对。孩子们，我是这么想的。我不是。对。我知道。我的孩子们，好吧，他们是在纽约长大的。而且他们，我觉得有两名身为名人的父母，会带来一些本身就存在的挑战。
And I wish that wasn't true. In a funny kind of way, you think to yourself, well, Kier and I have no one to blame but ourselves for being famous. But the kids, it was kind of thrust upon them in a way, right? They didn't ask for this. And there's a weird moment where they start to, you know, for the first time they start to go. You're holding a kid's hand and someone comes up and wants to, you know,
我希望事实并非如此。从某种搞笑的角度来看，你会对自己说：“好吧，我和基拉出名只能怪我们自己。”但对于孩子们来说，这有点像是强加给他们的，对吧？他们并没有要求这些。而且会有这样一个奇怪的时刻，他们开始，你知道的，生平第一次他们开始去……
take a picture or an autograph. You have to let that kid's hand go. Right. Yeah. Yeah. And the kid's like, what the fuck? I don't even know this guy. Right.
你正牵着孩子的手，有人走过来想，你知道的，拍张照或者要个签名。你不得不松开那个孩子的手。对。对。然后孩子就会想：“这他妈是闹哪样？我根本不认识这家伙。”对。
Like, why is this stranger, you know, stranger danger? By the way, you've taught them all stranger. Yeah, but that's the moment. It's an important lesson for them to learn when you let their hand go, which is what you're saying is my celebrity is more important to me than you. And they need to know that. Daddy's got to do something.
比如，为什么这个陌生人，你知道，有陌生人危险？顺便说一句，你已经教过他们所有的陌生人了。是的，但就是那个时刻。当你松开他们的手时，对他们来说这是一个重要的教训，这就好比你在说，我的名气对我来说比你更重要。他们需要知道这一点。爸爸得去做点事。
You know, it's funny. You know, it's funny. I just got back. So where I was on the East Coast all summer, we're out on Long Island, deep in Long Island, and it makes Jason crazy. It's so blue-collar. No, thanks, man. Yeah.
你知道，这挺搞笑的。你知道，这挺搞笑的。我刚回来。所以我整个夏天都在东海岸，我们在长岛，长岛深处，这让杰森抓狂。太工人阶级了。不，谢了，老兄。是的。
He's just running the bowling alley out there. Yeah. I work on diesel engines. Yeah. I work on diesel engines. Maybe I already told you this, but I was in the car. He's an officer fisherman. Yeah.
他就在那儿经营保龄球馆。是的。我修理柴油发动机。是的。我修理柴油发动机。也许我之前跟你说过这个，但我在车里。他是个岸上渔民。是的。
Checking my pots every day out there. So anyway, so I'm getting in the car with the kids in town, and this guy comes up and blah, blah, blah. I want to talk to his wife and want to take a picture and say, hey, man, they, by the way, the best part is now people come up and they're like, hey, tell Bateman, blah, blah, blah. And shot him, Scottie, and like, hey, you don't know them.
每天都在那儿查看我的虾笼。所以不管怎样，我带着孩子们在镇上上车，这个家伙走过来，巴拉巴拉。我想和他的妻子谈谈，想拍张照，说，嘿，老兄，他们，顺便说一句，最棒的部分是现在人们走过来会说，嘿，告诉贝特曼，巴拉巴拉。然后一枪崩了，斯科蒂，就像，嘿，你又不认识他们。
So shut the fuck up. But they go, the guy says all this stuff. So then I get in the car and my son, who's just turned 12, he's behind me, and I pull out of the parking spot in town, and he's kind of quiet in the car, and he just goes, hey, Will, you're a legend, man. And I go, hey, man.
所以给老子闭嘴。但他们说，这家伙说了一堆废话。然后我上了车，我那个刚满12岁的儿子，他坐在我身后，我把车从镇上的停车位开出来，他在车里有点安静，然后他就说，嘿，威尔，你真是个传奇，老兄。我说，嘿，老兄。
He starts hassling me from the back, mocking me from the back seat. You're the greatest, man, like this. I'm like, dude, I know, it's weird. I didn't, I'm sorry. They keep you real. And they keep me real. And I was like, but I was also happy
他开始在后面烦我，从后座嘲笑我。你是最棒的，老兄，就像这样。我说，老兄，我知道，这很诡异。我没想，我很抱歉。他们让你保持真实。他们让我保持真实。我当时想，但我也很高兴
that he had that kind of great kind of perspective on it. You know what I mean? Like it was kind of great. And he made fun of me, which was great. Oh, yeah. They get a really serious bullshit meter very, very early on because they can see it from the people that are surrounding their lives.
他对此有一种那种很棒的视角。你知道我的意思吗？就感觉挺棒的。而且他取笑了我，这很棒。哦，是的。他们很早就建立了一个非常严肃的狗屎运检测器，因为他们可以从周围生活中接触的人身上看出来。
And the other thing is, I feel like to a certain extent, you can't beat yourself up too much about it because that's what you do. That's what we do. So other people have other challenges. Yeah. We will be right back. And now back to the show.
另一件事是，我觉得在某种程度上，你不能太为难自己，因为这就是你的工作。这就是我们的工作。所以其他人有其他的挑战。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
So Kevin, how was the summer? Did you do anything super exciting this summer? Was it nice and chill and relaxed and just played that guitar in your shot there? I was spending a lot of time. We have a farm. And so I spent a lot of time with the animals and riding pretty much every day.
所以凯文，夏天过得怎么样？这个夏天你做了什么超级令人兴奋的事吗？过得挺悠闲放松、就在你那小破屋里弹吉他吗？我花了很多时间。我们有一个农场。所以我花了很多时间陪动物，几乎每天都在骑马。
And I was out with my brother touring. I have a band with my brother. Yeah. I was going to ask about that. Tell us about that. On the road now. So we've been playing. We were on one little run and I got the vid.
我跟我弟弟一起去巡演了。我和我弟弟有个乐队。是的。我正要问这个呢。跟我们讲讲那个吧。现在在路上。所以我们一直在演出。我们刚进行了一小段巡演，然后我中招了。
So we had to shut down. And then we picked those up. How was your time with that? Easy or? It wasn't great. Yeah. It wasn't great. But it was not, you know, I didn't go to the hospital
所以我们不得不叫停。然后我们又重新开始了。你那段时间过得怎么样？轻松还是？不太好。是的。不太好。但也没，你知道，我没去医院
or anything. So that was great. And then now we're out doing a little bit more playing. I did a movie. Yeah, movie, maybe a couple of them. I can't remember. I know. This is amazing.
或者什么的。所以那挺好的。然后现在我们又出去多演了几场。我拍了部电影。是的，电影，也许好几部。我记不清了。我知道。这太惊人了。
Like of course he did. I like the way he's like, I did a movie. Yeah, of course. Maybe I did too. I know. Maybe I did too. It's just a three month period recovering here. What was the thing for you?
就像他当然会这么做。我喜欢他那种语气，我拍了一部电影。对，当然。也许我也拍了。我知道。也许我也拍了。这只是一段在这里恢复的三个月的时期。对你来说，那是什么？
Who are the people that you kind of looked up to? Like creatively, who are the guys? Like when you were a teenager, you're like, I like this theater. I like that stuff. Like who is the man? Directors or actors? Yeah. Who is the Kevin Bacon?
你崇拜的人是谁？从创意角度来说，有哪些人？就像当你还是个青少年时，你会想，我喜欢这个剧院。我喜欢那些东西。谁是那个大咖？导演还是演员？是的。谁是你的凯文·贝肯？
Yeah. Who is your Kevin Bacon? Yeah, sure. Well, you know, for me, it was, okay, so I moved to New York, which is kind of when I think of my career as starting around 1976. You did a lot of theater there? I did a lot of theater. Yeah.
是的。谁是你的凯文·贝肯？是的，当然。嗯，你知道，对我来说，是，好吧，所以我搬到了纽约，这就有点像我把我的职业生涯视为始于1976年左右。你在那里演了很多戏剧吗？我演了很多戏剧。是的。
A lot of theater. And Animal House, I think I started in 1978, something like that. Was that your first film, Animal House? That was my first movie yet. Wow. But I can tell you that the people, at that point, to me, it was the movies and the people surrounding Sidney LaMette, Francis Ford, Coppola, Michael Cimino.
很多戏剧。还有《动物屋》，我想我是从1978年左右开始的，差不多那样。那是你的第一部电影吗，《动物屋》？那是我的第一部电影。哇。但我可以告诉你，在那个时候，对我来说，是电影以及围绕在西德尼·吕美特、弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉、迈克尔·西米诺身边的人。
So, you know, Da Nero, and Pacino, and Meryl Streep, and Raul Julia, and John Casale, and all of those gritty kind of like Dustin Hoffman. And really, one of the most influential things, yeah, yeah, for me was I saw, back to back, we had a dollar, in Philly, we had a dollar second-run theater. You could see films for a dollar. And back to back, they had The Graduate and Midnight Cowboy.
所以，你知道，德尼罗、阿尔·帕西诺、梅丽尔·斯特里普、劳尔·朱利亚、约翰·卡萨韦茨，所有那些坚毅的类型，就像达斯汀·霍夫曼。真的，最具影响力的事之一，对，对，对我来说是我看了，前后连着，我们在费城，我们有一个一美元的二轮影院。你可以花一美元看电影。前后脚，他们放映了《毕业生》和《午夜牛郎》。
Wow. And when I saw Dustin in that, I looked at Midnight Cowboy first. That was the first one that I saw, because they were both in second-run. And I went, wow, where'd they get that homeless guy to be in the movie? A cowboy. Where'd they get a cowboy and a homeless guy? How did they get them to actually do this?
哇。当我看到达斯汀在里面的表演时，我先看了《午夜牛郎》。那是看的第一部，因为它们都是二轮放映。我说，哇，他们从哪儿找来那个流浪汉来演电影？一个牛仔。他们从哪儿找来一个牛仔和一个流浪汉？他们是怎么让他们真的这么做的？
And then right after that... Cut to the preppy guy. Cut to the preppy guy. And I went, holy shit, that's what acting is. And that's the thing. Did you have a group of friends, though, at that time in high school who were in that same mindset as you, like, alone in this old, like, your own thing?
然后紧接着... 镜头切到那个常春藤盟校帅哥。 镜头切到那个常春藤盟校帅哥。 我就想，我靠，这才是表演。就是这样。不过，你当时在高中时有一群朋友，他们和你有相同的想法，就像，独自沉浸在这老派的、你自己的事情里？
I was alone in my own head about that, yeah. Yeah, the only thing is I had this one kid who I was friends with who was wealthy. And his father had something that was unheard of, which was a giant home video system. And I think it couldn't have been VHS. It must have been some other, like, really, really early... Or, like, laser disc. Remember laser disc?
关于这一点，我独自在自己的脑海里盘算，是的。是的，唯一的事是我有一个好朋友是个有钱人。他父亲拥有一样闻所未闻的东西，那是一个巨大的家用录像系统。我觉得那不可能是VHS。一定是什么别的，像，非常非常早期的... 或者，像是激光视盘。还记得激光视盘吗？
No, this was before that. And that was way before laser disc. Yeah, it was the 70s, yeah. And he turned me on to... He was obsessed with Brando and Clifton Dean and the switch in the style of acting that existed there. So he wasn't an actor, but he was a strange kind of movie buff. So I kind of got started into that stuff.
不，这在那之前。那比激光视盘早得多。对，那是70年代，是的。他带我接触了... 他痴迷于白兰哥和蒙哥马利·克利夫特，以及其中存在的表演风格的转变。所以他不是演员，但他是一个奇怪的电影迷。所以我算是开始接触那些东西了。
But yeah, those were my people. With all of that, and these guys will make fun of me because I ask this question all the time, but with all of that experience, that set experience, all the hundreds and hundreds of directors you've worked with... Have you thought about directing? No, he has directed. And my question is, do you not like it as much as acting?
但是是的，那些是我的圈子。考虑到所有这些，这几个人会取笑我，因为我老是问这个问题，但是带着所有的经验，那些片场经验，你合作过的成百上千的导演... 你有没有考虑过当导演？不，他当过导演。我的问题是，你是不是不像当演员那么喜欢它？
Given all that you've absorbed, do you not find it... that it demands all those things that you've absorbed beyond just the acting? Well, someday I want to really sit you down and sound you on your great work as a director, but also in your great work as directing yourself, which is something that I find really kind of incredibly... I've done it a little bit.
鉴于你吸收了那么多东西，你难道不觉得它...要求具备所有你吸收的东西，不仅仅是表演吗？嗯，改天我真想好好跟你坐下来聊聊，听听你作为导演的出色工作，还有你在自我导演方面得出色的工作，我觉得这真的有点不可思议... 我自己也做过一点。
I've directed City on a Hill, but I find that really kind of mind-blowing. People can do that well. You're aware of how you're performing while you're performing, right? You're sort of self-directing the whole time, aren't you? When you do your thing, yeah. I am. I think it's less about knowing if I got it or not and more about just the overwhelming,
我执导过《山丘上的城市》，但我发现那真的很让人脑洞大开。人们能把那个做好。你在表演的同时意识到自己是如何表演的，对吧？你其实一直在自我导演，对不对？当你做你那一套时，是的。我是。我觉得这与其说知不知道自己演得到不到位，不如说是一种排山倒海般的、
consumptive thing that happens to you when you have to direct and you have to answer questions from dawn to dusk and then beyond. Just having all that kind of responsibility and then also being able to 100% throw yourself into the role. I would like to direct more. But as you know, when it comes to a film, that's an easy year of your life, done, right? So I keep getting these acting gigs that I go,
消耗精力的事，当你要当导演，要从早到晚甚至更晚回答各种问题时，这种事就会降临到你头上。只要拥有所有那种责任感，然后还能百分之百地投入到角色中去。我挺想多当导演的。但如你所知，说到拍电影，那就是你生活中轻松的一年，搞定，对吧？所以我一直接到那些演戏的活儿，然后我就想，
oh, man, but I haven't been that guy yet. So I really keep going back to acting, but it'll happen again. Do you ever develop... I'm forgiving because I think I should know this answer. I don't know if I can forgive you until I hear what it is. Oh, you're asking Kev, okay. He's forgotten his name.
噢，天哪，但我还没演过那家伙呢。所以我真的总是回去演戏，但这种事还会再发生的。你有没有开发过... 我很健忘，因为我觉得我应该知道这个答案。在听到答案之前，我不知道能不能原谅你。哦，你是在问凯夫，好吧。他忘了自己的名字了。
Mr. Bacon, do you develop stuff for yourself, do you develop your own thing for yourself, like roles for yourself and do you enjoy doing that or is that like a big headache? I love that. I love that, I really do. Yeah, I do. I'm always looking for books, stories, ideas.
贝肯先生，你有没有为自己开发过东西，你有没有为自己开发过属于你自己的东西，比如为自己量身打造角色，你喜欢这样做吗，还是说这就像是一个巨大的头疼事？我喜欢那个。我真的非常喜欢。是的，我喜欢。我一直在寻找书籍、故事、创意。
We have something that we're working on now. Kira and I are both involved in it. It's a little bit of a secret, but we're... Yeah, I really do. I like the development process. I mean, it can be a little... It can be a little frustrating, as you all know, when you put a lot of time into something and you go out,
我们现在手头正有些在弄的东西。基拉和我都有参与。这算是个小秘密，但我们... 是的，我真的很喜欢。我喜欢开发过程。我是说，这可能会有点... 可能会有点令人沮丧，正如你们大家所知，当你把很多时间投入到某件事上然后你出去，
you take it around town and it gets passed on all over town, which happens, but we still try to keep it going. Okay, so now you've done so many different types of character and whatever, and I'm gonna ask you the most basic question. Good guys or bad guys? What do you like playing more? Well... Because you do them both so fucking well.
你带着它在城里到处跑，结果全城上下都把它给PASS了，这种情况时有发生，但我们还是设法让它继续下去。好吧，所以现在你演了这么多不同类型的角色什么的，我要问你最基本的问题。好人还是坏人？你更喜欢演哪种？嗯... 因为你这两类都演他妈的太棒了。
Yeah. I don't care. I mean, I don't care if the character is a well-written, complicated, interesting character, if he's a good guy or a bad guy, I don't care. The thing that I don't do is worry about what the character does and how it's going to reflect on me as a person. I don't care at all what people think of me image-wise.
是的。我不在乎。我是说，我不在乎这个角色是一个写得好、复杂、有趣的角色，不管是好人还是坏人，我都不在乎。我不做的事是担心这个角色做什么，以及它将如何作为一个人反映在我身上。我根本不在乎别人在形象上怎么看我。
I really just want to be known for the work. It's a little bit of a hassle in this career, as I've come to learn, is that there is this other thing outside of the work that I almost wish didn't even exist. If I could just go... And the present company excluded, if I could just go and just say the lines and hit the marks and not have to do any of the rest of it, I would.
我真的只想凭作品闻名。正如我后来了解到的，在这个行业里这稍微有点麻烦，那就是在作品之外还有这样另一样东西，我甚至希望它根本不存在。如果我能直接去...抛开在座的各位不谈，如果我能直接去说台词、找准位置，而不需要去做其他任何事，我愿意。
But when it comes to taking on things that are people that do horrible shit or are... I've done a lot of terrible, terrible things in the characters I've played. That doesn't scare me at all. It's not so much that the character is good or bad as it is. Are they complex? Are they different than the guy that I just played?
但当涉及到扮演那些做过可怕事情的人或者... 我在我演过的角色里做过很多可怕、可怕的事情。那一点也不吓人。与其说角色是好是坏，不如说是。他们复杂吗？他们跟我刚刚演过的那个家伙不同吗？
Is there just good shit to play? You guys know. Do you ever get close to thinking about... I've done enough of this. What about full-time music now? Yeah, Bacon Brothers. Do you ever get close to that? No, I still really love being an actor.
有没有什么好玩的角色可以演？你们都知道。你有没有想过... 我已经演够这个了。现在全职搞音乐怎么样？是的，贝肯兄弟。你有没有接近过那种状态？不，我仍然非常热爱当演员。
But the music you love, love doing, right? I love the music. And we've just put out new music. I've been doing a lot of writing. I continue to write. It's one of those things where what really keeps driving the band is not so much the desire to... I mean, people would find this hard to believe,
但你热爱音乐，热爱创作，对吧？我热爱音乐。我们刚刚发布了新音乐。我一直在进行大量创作。我继续在写作。这就属于那种真正推动乐队前进的动力并不是那么渴望去... 我是说，人们可能会觉得这很难相信，
but it's not really that I want to be a rock star fantasy. Definitely that was in there when I was a kid for sure. All my heroes had guitars. That was the deal when I was in my early teens. But you write a song, and then you play your song for your wife, and then you play a song for your brother, and then you want to put it out in front of people, and then you want to cut it.
但这真的不是因为我想实现摇滚巨星的梦想。我小时候肯定有过那种幻想。我所有的英雄都有吉他。那是我十几岁时的标配。但你写了一首歌，然后你把你的歌弹给你的妻子听，然后你把一首歌弹给你弟弟听，然后你想把它放到人们面前，然后你想把它录制下来。
So if the songwriting keeps coming, that's just really what drives it. Yeah, I love that. And it's you and your brother, Michael, right? Yeah, me and my brother, Mike, yeah. Yeah, we put the band together probably in 1995. He's about nine years old with the band, and he's a musician.
所以如果歌曲创作源源不断，那才是真正推动它的动力。是的，我喜欢这样。那是你和你弟弟迈克，对吧？是的，我和我弟弟迈克，是的。是的，我们大概在1995年组建了这支乐队。他大体上和乐队差不多大，他是个音乐家。
He's a composer. He can arrange. He writes. He's got awards. He's like a classically trained musician. I'm just a plunker. I love that. Wait a minute.
他是个作曲家。他会编曲。他会创作。他拿过奖。他就像是个受过古典训练的音乐家。我只是个乱弹琴的。我喜欢这个。等一下。
How many kids in your family? Six. I'm the youngest of six. I'm the youngest of five. I have a brother named Kevin and Michael. Who are your other siblings? Wow. We have four sisters.
你家里有几个孩子？六个。我是六个里面最小的。我是五个里面最小的。我有一个叫凯文和一个叫迈克的兄弟。你的其他兄弟姐妹是谁？哇。我们有四个姐妹。
Yeah, four sisters. My sister, Karen, my sister, Eleanor, Hilda, and Kira, who's, she changed her name to Kira, spelled slightly differently than my wife, because my parents were terrible name givers, and they named her Prudence. And she was like probably about, I don't know, 18 or 19. She was like, fuck this, Prudence.
是的，四个姐妹。我姐姐凯伦，我姐姐埃莉诺，希尔达，还有基拉，她，她把名字改成了基拉，拼写跟我妻子稍微有点不同，因为我父母是糟糕的起名废，他们给她取名叫普鲁登斯。她大概，我不知道，18或19岁的时候。她就觉得，去他妈的，普鲁登斯。
Are you kidding me? I wasn't going to say that your parents are terrible name givers. I was just going to say, though, I remarked that both you and your brother, you go, you like Kevin. He likes Mike instead of Michael and Kevin. So that's no. No, they were not good.
你在开玩笑吧？我本来没打算说你父母是糟糕的起名废。我只是想说，我注意到你和你弟弟，你们两个，你喜欢凯文。他喜欢迈克而不是迈克尔和凯文。所以这不。不，他们不擅长。
They were not good with the names. They were not good with the names. Now, our kids. What were their names? Their names were Edmund and Ruth. Our kids are named Travis and Sosie, and you'll get a kick out of this. Both names came off of crew lists when Kira was pregnant.
他们不擅长起名字。他们不擅长起名字。现在，我们的孩子。他们的名字是什么？他们的名字叫埃德蒙和露丝。我们的孩子叫特拉维斯和索茜，你绝对想不到这个。这两个名字都是基拉怀孕时从剧组职员名单上抄下来的。
So. Oh, really? Yeah. She was shooting something pregnant. And we just, we found out she's pregnant. We just go down to the crew list and pick a name. No way. Sosie.
所以。哦，真的吗？是的。她怀孕时在拍戏。然后我们，我们发现她怀孕了。我们直接去看剧组职员名单然后随便挑了个名字。不会吧。索茜。
Jason, you can relate to that, right? Sosie, S-O-S-I-E. Sosie, yeah. I know. And she's a great actress. It's amazing. Thank you. Thank you.
杰森，你能感同身受，对吧？索茜，S-O-S-I-E。索茜，是的。我知道。她是个很棒的演员。太惊人了。谢谢。谢谢。
Yeah, she's doing great. I love her. I'm a big fan of her. Thank you. But that's so awesome that you and your brother have this, this connection with something that you both love and that you get to do together. I love that idea that you guys have been sort of
是的，她干得很棒。我很喜欢她。我是她的超级粉丝。谢谢。但太棒了，你和你弟弟有这种，这种对你们都热爱并且能一起做的事情的连接。我很喜欢你们这种
doing it for a long time. Yeah. And I want to see you guys play. I know. I know. We should. Speaking of music, Sean, I can't wait to hear your, see your show.
已经做了很久的想法。是的。我想看你们演出。我知道。我知道。我们应该去。说到音乐，肖恩，我等不及要听你的，看你的演出。
Is it coming into New York? Oh, thanks. Yeah, that's very nice of you. Yeah. Good night, Oscar. It opens at, it's at the Belasco Theater, and we open April 7th. The Belasco Theater?
是要去纽约上演吗？哦，谢谢。是的，你太好了。是的。晚安，奥斯卡。它将在，它在贝拉斯科剧院上演，我们4月7日开演。贝拉斯科剧院？
Go to Belasco. That's so exciting. That's so exciting. Belasco Theater. April 7th? Is that what she said, Sean? Opening the Belasco Theater. April 7th, 2023, I think.
去贝拉斯科。太令人兴奋了。太令人兴奋了。贝拉斯科剧院。4月7日？她是这么说的吗，肖恩？在贝拉斯科剧院开演。2023年4月7日，我想。
W-W-W. Listen, Kevin. Thank you, Kevin. What about if you and Mike write a musical for Sean? That would be something, right? Yes. There you go. Come on.
听着，凯文。谢谢你，凯文。要是你和迈克为肖恩写一部音乐剧怎么样？那一定很有意思，对吧？是的。这就对了。来吧。
Well, you'd have to be in it. How do you feel about rock musical? Yes. Do you like singing rock? Yeah. I mean, it's kind of what I'm known for. Sing some rock, Sean, real quick for us, just so we can get...
嗯，你得亲自参演。你觉得摇滚音乐剧怎么样？是的。你喜欢唱摇滚吗？是的。我是说，这差不多是我出名的领域。肖恩，快给我们唱一段摇滚，好让我们...
I'm baking in the morning, baking in the evening, baking all summer night. Oh, it's funny. You're singing about bacon, but it seems like your brain is full of scrambled eggs because that was terrible. Hey, listen, Kev, we have...
早晨贝肯，晚上贝肯，整个夏天的夜晚都在贝肯。哦，这太搞笑了。你唱的是贝肯（培根），但看起来你的脑子装满了炒鸡蛋，因为那太糟糕了。嘿，听着，凯夫，我们有...
Horrible. That was horrible. That was horrible. We monopolized your time. I feel like we could talk to you for about three hours. You're just such a good dude. You are the greatest. I wish our paths across...
太难听了。那太难听了。那太难听了。我们垄断了你的时间。我觉得我们可以跟你聊大约三个小时。你真是个好人。你太棒了。我希望我们的轨迹能交汇...
We'd crossed paths more, but hopefully we will in the future, man. You're just... You're a good dude, and you're so good at what you do. Thank you, guys. Thank you for doing this, Kevin. It's been a lot of fun.
我们能有更多交集，但希望我们以后会有，老兄。你真是个...你是个好人，而且你对自己的工作如此精益求精。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们做这个，凯文。这真的很有趣。
Thank you. We love you so much. Bye, pal. Okay. Talk to you soon. Okay, pal. Peace. He's something else, huh?
谢谢。我们非常爱你。再见，老兄。好的。回聊。好的，老兄。拜。他可真不一般，哈？
Yeah. Old Kay Bakes. Love him. Kay Bakes. Kay Bakes. Can we start that? Yeah, we're starting Kay Bakes right now. By the way, if you see...
是的。老凯贝克斯。爱他。凯贝克斯。凯贝克斯。我们能开始叫这外号吗？是的，我们现在就叫他凯贝克斯。顺便说一句，如果你看到...
If you happen to see Kev on the street, old Kay Bakes, just go up to him and say, hey, Kay Bakes, you know? Feel free. Because he... We have got to start that. If you see Kevin baking on the street.
如果你碰巧在街上看到凯夫，老凯贝克斯，就走过去对他说，嘿，凯贝克斯，你知道吗？随便。因为他...我们必须开始这么叫。如果你在街上看到凯文·贝肯。
On the street. Hey, Kay Bakes. What up, Kay Bakes? It's like cupcakes. Yeah. What's... We need to bake cupcakes with his face on it. Man, how many...
在街上。嘿，凯贝克斯。怎么样，凯贝克斯？就像纸杯蛋糕一样。是的。我们要...我们需要烤印有他脸的纸杯蛋糕。老兄，有多少...
So how many films has he done, Willie? You said a whole page. Yeah. He has his own... I wonder if he's hit a... He's probably hit 100. He has to. I'm going to say...
所以他拍了多少部电影，威利？你说了一整页。是的。他有他自己的...我不知道他有没有达到...他大概已经100部了。他肯定有。我要说是...
100 movies. So that would mean... So he's been in the business since he was 15. What do you think he is now? It won't listen. I mean, 5.53. Do you think he's 60 yet? What's his birthday?
100部电影。那意味着...所以他从15岁就开始在这个行业了。你觉得他现在多大？它不会听。我是说，5.53。你觉得他到60岁了吗？他的生日是...
Well, he looks... No, I know how old he is, and you try to guess, because he looks incredible. Well, if I'm 53, then he might not yet be 60, but he's older than I am. Sean, what do you think?
嗯，他看起来...不，我知道他多大，而你试着去猜，因为他看起来不可思议。好吧，如果我53岁，那他可能还没到60岁，但他比我大。肖恩，你觉得呢？
I was going to say late 50s. You ready for this? I'm ready. 64. Wow. Yeah. All right. So then he's been doing it for 50 years.
我本想说快50多岁。你准备好听这个了吗？我准备好了。64岁。哇。是的。好吧。那他已经干了50年了。
He's been doing it since... What do you say? 1976 was his first acting gig. 1976 when he did that ROTC. Right. So we're coming up on 50 years. Yeah. Right?
他从...你刚才说什么？1976年是他的第一份演艺工作。1976年他演那个的时候。对。所以我们快接近50年了。是的。对吧？
That's amazing. So that's two films a year. He's probably done 100 films. I love when he was like... I think I did two films last year. I know, he can't. And it's so funny. I think that's like a baseball player,
这太惊人了。所以那是每年两部电影。他大概拍了100部电影。我喜欢他刚才说...我想我去年拍了两部电影。我知道，他不能。这太搞笑了。我觉得这就像一个棒球运动员，
you know, 3,000 hits or something. I think if you do 100 movies, that is a real award for one-to-one. 100 movies, and also television, and he's done series in there too. And the movies, I mean, he's worked with everybody. Barry Levinson. There's a reason it's six degrees of Kevin Bacon, right?
你知道的，3000安打什么的。我觉得如果你拍了100部电影，对任何人来说这都是一个真正的荣誉。100部电影，还有电视，而且他还在其中拍过电视剧。还有那些电影，我是说，他跟所有人都合作过。巴里·莱文森。凯文·贝肯的六度分隔理论是有原因的，对吧？
Yeah. I mean, I don't think you can do that about it. You know, when I was really happy that we didn't bring that up. I was too. I was very proud of us. Can you imagine how exhausted he is hearing about that? Yeah, but don't you kind of want to talk about it?
是的。我是说，我觉得你不能那样。你知道的，当时我很高兴我们没有提起那个。我也是。我为我们感到骄傲。你能想象他听到那个有多厌烦吗？是的，但你难道不有点想聊聊吗？
I think he made up for it with the footloose references. Yeah, I know. Sean went straight away with the footloose references. I know. He made off stuff. I mean, what are you doing? Hey, man. Hey, man.
我觉得他用那些《浑身是劲》的梗弥补了这一点。对，我知道。肖恩直接就用上了《浑身是劲》的梗。我知道。他编造东西。我是说，你在干嘛？嘿，老兄。嘿，老兄。
Do you lose a bunch of dough? God. Hey, this is a subject I'm sure you want to talk about. Yeah, in minute five. Yeah. I was just curious again. Hey, kid, what was your biggest disappointment? We had to warm up the guest.
你亏了一大笔钱吗？天哪。嘿，这是个你肯定想聊的话题。是的，在第五分钟。是的。我只是又很好奇。嘿，孩子，你最大的失望是什么？我们不得不热场嘉宾。
What are you doing, Sean? I thought I was actually genuinely interested. I'm sure there's other people that are genuinely interested. What did Skeva, when he got on the hear, did he clip part of the brain out? What happened? Did he? Have you got a leak back there?
你在干什么，肖恩？我以为我其实是真的感兴趣。我确信还有其他人是真的感兴趣。凯夫当他听到这个时，他大脑的一部分被切除藏起来了吗？发生什么事了？是吗？你后面有什么东西漏了吗？
What happened? No, the only leak is my Swedish fish leak. Yeah. No. Get a clamp on that. Oh, gosh. Everybody thinking about a bye? Here comes Will.
怎么回事？不，唯一漏的是我的瑞典鱼软糖漏了。是的。不，管好那个。哦，天哪。每个人都在想再见？威尔来了。
Yeah, I'm just going to say, it's just gay. It's got something to do with Swedish fish. We just think you have all that Swedish fish and it builds up in the back there into a big lump. You might want to get it. Bye, Uppsy. Bye! Bye!
是的，我只想说，这只是个玩笑。它跟瑞典鱼软糖有关。我们只是觉得你吃了所有那些瑞典鱼软糖，然后在后面堆集成了一个大疙瘩。你可能想把它处理掉。再见，阿普西。再见！再见！
Bye, everyone! Bye, Uppsy. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Let's. Smart.
再见，各位！再见，阿普西。再见。再见。明智。让我们。明智。让我们。明智。让我们。明智。让我们。明智。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔德杰夫和贝内特·巴比科、巴贝卡100%有机纯手工制作的。巴贝卡。
Let's. Smart. Let's. Smart. Let's. Smart. Let's. SmartLess is 100% organic in artisanly hand-crafted by Michael
还没有人为这集发表评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Grant Terry, Rob Armdjerve, and Benet Barbicoe. Barbeca. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆杰尔夫和贝内特·巴比科。巴贝卡。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。